معنى الان للعوده مراسله في القدس اهلا بك
ليله نتوقف معك عند مستجدات الوضع بعض
الانفجارين قرب في محطتين الحافلات في
القدس بنجانس اجتمع مسؤول عسكريين وامنيين
هل اتضحت الصوره اكثر فاكثر
مساء الخير من حيث نتواجد من موقع
الانفجار الذي وقع صباح اليوم في السابع
ونصف بتوقيت المحليه عند مدخل مدينه القدس
بالفعل انتهى الاجتماع الامن الذي تاسه
رئيس الوزراء رئيس هذا الاجتماع لم يتم
الاعلان عن نتائج حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن
الذي اجتمع بالقاده الامنيين اطلع همم
رئيس الوزراء المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو على
نتائج هذا الاجتماع دون الافصاح عن نتائج
بطبيعه الحال كما قلت حيث نتواجد هنا في
موقع العمليه همم لا يزال عدد كبير من همم
المتدينين اليهود والصحافه يتواجهون هنا
همم هنا بالضبط تمت عمليات التفجير عند
محطه الحافلات لا زالت هناك اجراءات امنيه
كما نعلم همم في همم عين المكان لفحص اييي
ان كانت هناك ادله او ما شابه هنا تقام
صلوات بعد هذا الانفجار بطبيعه الحال هذا
الموقع كما ااا نعلم همم حيوي في ساعه
الصباح الذي وقع بها الانفجار كانت ساعه
الذروه صباحا كان هناك تواجد لا باس به من
الاسرائيليين همم وبطبيعه الحال كما نشاهد
هنا تواجد صحفي تواجد لاسرائيليين اود ان
اوضح بان هذا المكان هو بالفعل مدخل القدس
الرئيسي من الجهه الغربيه من هنا يتم
الدخول من
تل ابيب بالاساس الى مدينه القدس في جزءها
الغربي ولذلك تكون في ساعات الصباحيه
ساعات الذروه في ردود الفعل هناك بطبيعه
الحال بنيامين نتنياهو سرحه قبل قليل قال
بان هناك نيه لاستعاده الامن للاسرائيليين
وبانه يكون هناك سماح بان يكون هناك سلطه
او قوه لما اسمائها بالارهاب وبطبيعه
الحال كانت هناك تصريحات لرئيس الوزراء
ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي حاله من الغضب
كانت في اوساط اليمين تحديدا من قبل
المتشدد لتمر بن جفير الذي يطالب بوزاره
الامن وقال بانه يريد استلام هذه الوزاره
من اجل ان يكون هناك استثباب للامن وسيطر
على الارهاب ودعاء الى العوده الى سياسه
الاغتيالات ضد الفلسطينيين جزيل الشكر لكي
ليلى عوده مراسلات فرانس 24 في القدس على
كل هذه التفاصيل والت